[Applause]
well hello and welcome to the pandemi's
the la staple center was packed at
sunday's 2020 emmy awards
just kidding we're living in the era of
covid
and social distancing so no one was at
this year's award show
and what the hell am i doing here this
is the year they decide they have to
have a host
well no one besides hosts jimmy kimmel
and
a few other celeb participants i'd like
to have one joke for every nominee so i
think we'll have about 900
in the show we filled the seats with
cardboard cutouts of the nominees you
can see we have regina king
hugh jackman jason bateman meryl streep
wait a minute go back one jason bateman
was the first famous face to join jimmy
irl but the ozark actor's visit was
short-lived you can stay as long as you
promise to laugh at my jokes
huh i'm out i'm gonna call the car
jennifer aniston also dropped by the
venue to present the evening's first
award
i said thanks jimmy what
never never mind the morning show
actress's appearance was
literally on fire okay now we just need
to sanitize the envelope
okay here we go
perfect one cannot skip the carpet
and tracy ellis ross might have been
socially distant at home when catherine
o'hara was named the winner of her lead
actress in a comedy series category
but the blackish star was on set with
jimmy when it came time to present
but tracy yes you forgot to present the
award
no no no i agreed to dress for the
occasion
and come somewhere other than my home
and i have done that it was really nice
so good night ellis's co-star anthony
anderson emphasized the record number of
black nominees at this year's emmys
while paying kimmel a visit
this is the part where the white people
start to applaud
oh and not oh
and he went on to lead the late-night
host in a chant
say it with me jimmy black lives matter
louder jimmy
louder jimmy say it so that my kids
could hear it
other stars like zendaya laverne cox and
yara shahidi
also stopped by the stage so did jason
sedakis who announced his category while
getting a covid swab
oh wow that's deep you're in there okay
wow
meanwhile her made her emmy's debut with
a touching in memoriam tribute to the
stars we've lost over the past year
and sterling k brown closed out the
evening with
a little humor and we ain't showing up
to work unless we get some big
ass raises i'm presenting
we weren't even nominated
i will be at work tomorrow happily and
on time
and without complaint